[موسيقى]
طول المنتخب الارجنتيني حامل لقب كاس
العالم مع 20 22 يضيء ليل العاصمه
الارجنتينيه
الى قسمين على يمين الشاشه هذه هي الحافله
التي تقل اعضاء المنتخب الارجنتيني وعلى
اليسار وتابع الشارع
احد شوارع العاصمه
الارجنتينيه اقتضادا من طريق المطار ليصل
بيه العاصمه واحياؤها هذا الشارع رغم ان
الساعه متاخره جدا الثالثه بعد منتصف
الليل الثالثه تقريبا
في العاصمه الارجنتينيه لوصول
المنتخب الارجنتيني حامل لقب المونديال
الى بلاده ولان الكره ليست مساله رياضه
فقط الكره هي انسان الكره هي واحده هي
الشعور هي موقف بين البشر وهي وطنيه حين
يشعر كل افراد البلد والمواطنين بانهم تحت
اسم واحد اسم بلدها ومنتخب بلادهم يشعرون
بالفخر يتحدون مجددا حتى نحن العرب اتحدنا
مجددا بعد ان شعرنا بان المنتخبات العربيه
تمثلها وان كنا من جنسيات مختلفه للفوز
الثالث في تاريخ الارجنتين يعني صبرهم
طاليا نادين من عام 1986 هما ينتظروا
اللحظه التاريخيه بعد كل بطوله لكاس
العالم تحققت في قطر وحصل للمنتخب
الارجنتيني على اللقب للمره الثالثه في
تاريخه وقاد اللقب الاسطوره ميسي حاملا
كاس العالم واصلا اليوم الى الارجنتين
وعلى فكره ميسي يعتبر رغم انه حصل على
كثير من الجوائز وعمل جاهدا لكي يحصل على
اللقب ولكن الحظ حالفه لكي يخطر مسيرته
وهو في القمه وهو في يعني هو
حظيع بهذا الشرف بشرف التشويش في اخر
مونديال له رغم انه ما زالت المعلومات
متضاربه حتى الان ان كان سيكمل مسيرته
الرياضيه لكن المونديال هذا كان اخر
لحظات الصور
طائره المنتخب الارجنتيني وخرج منها ميسي
اول الوصلين رافي عن كاس العالم الكاس
العالم الذي انتظر جميع محبي ميسي ان يحصل
عليه اخيرا وان يرفعه قبل همم يعني اخر
موديل وكان العالم يقول بانه فوز منتخب
ميسي على فرنسا يعني كانت هي الحقائق وكان
ميسي يعامل هذا الكاس وكانه احد ابنائه
يقبله كل لحظه يحضنه همم
ميسي يعني حقق حلوه في الارض عربيه لفوز
تاريخي بالمونديال هو الثالث لها تاريخيا
وصول المنتخب اليوم وصول الابطال حاملا
كاس العالم الى بيونس ايرس هذا الحضور
الجماهيري حضور الشعبي الغفير بانتظار
ابالهم منتخب الارجنتين ونشير ايضا بان
كاس العالم الذي اقيم في دوله خليجيه هو
ابرز هذه الدول على الخارطه وضع العالم
العربي ودول الخليج اكثر فاكثر في خارطه
العالم بعد ان كانت
المواطنين والجماهير في بلدان بعيده كل
البعد عنا لا تعرف هذه المنطقه لا تعرف
عاداتها لا تعرف ثقافاتها لكن اليوم من
خلال هذه المونديال تعرفت اكثر واحترمت
هذه الثقافه واعجبت بها واشيلت بها اليوم
العالم اجمع يعرف دول الخليج من خلال
احتفاليات وما حصل على طوال شهر كامل
بعد ثالثه اليوم فجرا بتوقيت بيانس ايرس
بتوقيت الارجنتيني وهذا الحضور الشعبي
الغفير وهذا الانتظار الشعب الكبير
للابطال الكبار